merci d'être là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va défendre la gauche comme il se
doit en liga
[Musique]
des libéraux ce qu'ils sont en train de
faire c'est que maintenant ils nous paye
au rabais ça veut dire les petites
courses on a perdu entre 1 euro 50 voire
d'euros 29,3 euros 2 en un nom sur une
commande c'est quand même abusé
et pour les grandes distances ils ont
augmenté de cours à 2 30 40 centimes
dont on sait très bien qu'en septembre
va être un feu de paille et volières
descente donc j'ai nouveau diviser nos
salaires en deux et nous on veut se
battre pour remonter les prix à 5 euros
pour un minimum 5 euros
j'étais loi sur du 2002 net on va dire
je trouvais ça un peu déjà pour 55
heures de travail alors là je vais me
trouver en première à 1600 1200 euros et
100 couvertures sociales sans rien du
tout on est des auto-entrepreneurs on
n'a rien du tout nous derrière on se
casse une patte demain constate une
jambe des libéraux déjà d'une voix ne va
pas nous dire oui on est de tout coeur
avec vous bon rétablissement ils en ont
rien à de tout ailleurs ils vont
dire fois bombe à une épaule et aux
pauvres c'est pas grave pour lui et tant
pis pour lui on a nos petits travers
l'homme
[Musique]
d'accord c'est comme ça c'est un site
les clients allaient se plaindre auprès
des libraires c'est ainsi que les
clients font soit par téléphone soit sur
internet pour moi ça va très vite
twitter et enfin à mettre la pression
des libéraux seraient très minces des
libéraux ont ils chérissent leur client
ça va
rousset a vraiment
on discute avec bloquent l'accès aux
livres des livres à nos collègues pour
ça on voit que accès pour qu'il ne
puisse pas récupérer leur commande afin
d'impacter les chefs d'atr de denver le
but c b libéraux ils accueillent aucune
commande il songe resteront des libéraux
ne fasse pas d'argent il était donc
commerçants impactés par cette graisse
comprenait le ras-le-bol des
desbordes et vous ouais bien sûr bien
sûr
un moment donné quand on fait un travail
et
c'est aussi pour s'y retrouver à la fin
du mois c'est aussi pour pouvoir se
faire plaisir et vous ce soir en tant
que restaurateurs grecs
j'en ai pris jusqu'à temps qu'ils
arrivent j'en ai pris là maintenant les
gars sont passés j'ai fermé le
restaurant je vais appeler les clients
qui ont des commandes chez nous encore
pour leur dire que malheureusement ils
ne seront pas livrés parce que les
livreurs ne veulent plus livrer
donc c'est pas plus mal ils vont sortir
de chez eux et manger aussi même si pour
nous c'est ainsi une perte parce que
aujourd'hui
la livraison à domicile c'est une vraie
part de marché qui n'est pas négligeable
pour nous clairement
[Musique]